wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando sono stata per la prima volta la
siglia sulle ande cilene dove ci sono i
grandi telescopi dell'osservatorio
europeo australe
alzando gli occhi al cielo in una notte
senza luna mi sono ritrovata con le
lacrime per cui la bellezza infinita
sconvolgente che era tutto intorno a me
e della quale prendevo consapevolezza
sono in quel momento pur essendo
astronoma già da diversi anni in conto
con un cielo stellato intego è infatti
un'esperienza che cambia la tua
prospettiva nel mondo e non si può
raccontare ma è necessario viverla per
rimanere estasiati proprio come
ascoltare un notturno di chopin nel
silenzio assoluto dopo che si è rimasti
sommersi dal rumore è un dato di fatto
che nessuno può raccontarci la musica
proprio come nessuno può descriverti un
cielo stellato inalterato
oggi chi ha meno di 60 anni e non ha mai
avuto l'opportunità di fare un viaggio
in un posto remoto e disabitato molto
spesso non sa quanta bellezza ci sia
sopra le nostre teste durante una notte
serena l'italia l'europa tutto il nord
america molte regioni del globo
terrestre sono completamente inondate di
luce durante la notte e noi non abbiamo
la percezione questa di questa bellezza
la via lattea che è la nostra casa del
nell'universo è oggi diventata
invisibile per gran parte degli italiani
e per addirittura un terzo dell'umanità
e non è più sufficiente vivere in un
piccolo paese di montagna per fare
esperienza con un cielo impiego la luce
non ha confini
parte dai lampioni a globo che abbiamo
nei nostri giardini dalle insegne dei
negozi topo illuminate dai centri urbani
che più piccoli se non sempre
esageratamente
presente le luci e via via dalle città
della pianura vicenza padova verona fino
a milano la luce viaggia e disturba da
oltre 200 km
in pochi decenni la notte è stata
completamente soffocata dalle luci di
strade e città e non ci siamo nemmeno
resi conto che illuminando sempre un
pochino di più ci siamo persi la
possibilità di godere di uno spettacolo
naturale
meraviglioso la mia generazione è ancor
più che ha vissuto la propria maturità
durante il boom economico ha fatto poco
o niente per contrastare una
illuminazione eccessiva ed
energeticamente insostenibile che ha
cancellato l'esperienza della notte così
come l'hanno vissuta scrittori poeti
artisti musicisti pittori o più
semplicemente contadini e pastori fino a
grosso modo ad un secolo fa e se oggi
van gogh dovesse dipingere una delle sue
celebri notti stellate
avrebbe ben pochi oggetti da pennellare
su un fondo che ha reso marroncino dalle
top e luce al sodio la luna qualche
pianeta è solo le stelle più brillanti
di questo ce ne rendiamo conto quando
improvvisamente una città rimane senza
corrente elettrica per un black out
ricompare la via lattea e riconosciamo
nuovamente le costellazioni così come
l'hanno descritta e gli antichi greci e
il cielo torna ad essere un velluto
scuro dove scintillano opali smeraldi
lapislazzuli urbini come scrive vincent
al fratello theo in una lettera del 1888
ma possiamo ancora spegnere le luci per
poter guardare il cielo e renderci conto
di quello che abbiamo perduto in poesia
e fantasia e forse in libertà come ci ha
lasciato scritto mario rigoni stern
qualche tentativo è stato fatto anche
qui sull'altopiano grazie alla
perseveranza dell'agenzia regionale per
la protezione ambientale del veneto
arpav con i nostri istituti di ricerca
astronomica e in collaborazione con
degli amministratori illuminati e non
abbagliati queste sono alcune immagini
del cielo
sopra cima ekar dove ci sono i più
grandi telescopi ottici sul suolo
nazionale che noi gestiamo già da alcuni
decenni in una qualunque in a8 invernale
verso la piana di asiago vediamo il mare
di luci e questa è una stella stessa
immagine ripresa durante la notte buia
del 2014 quando l'amministrazione
comunale di asiago ha spento per alcune
ore le luci pubbliche per permetterci di
fare alcune misurazioni del fondo cielo
effettivamente in quell'occasione
abbiamo registrato un miglioramento
nella qualità del cielo fino al 30 per
cento però è anche chiaro da questa
fotografia che molto inquinamento
luminoso arriva dagli impianti privati
che non sono stati spenti in
quell'occasione dai comuni limitrofi e
ovviamente dalla pianura e questo fa
permanere una perenne chiarore
all'orizzonte che spegnere stelle e
rende scialbo il cielo
senza il contributo di tutti rimaniamo
sempre come comunque lontani da quel
numero magico di stelle visibili ad
occhio nudo per il quale si innesca e
noi l'intuizione della tridimensionalità
dell'universo che ci lascia
letteralmente a bocca aperta quasi persi
dentro all'infinito
questo si vive in pochissimi luoghi
ormai in europa come la in italia
l'atlante di cinzano e falchi dello
scorso anno sul numero di stelle
visibili ad occhio nudo in italia ci
mostra che noi possiamo fare un po di
esperienza ancora di cielo veramente
integro e buio in una piccolissima zona
quasi al 100 della sardegna e in due
paesini sperduti in montagna quasi al
confine con l'austria in val senales e
in valle aurina nient'altro in italia
ma cosa può fare ognuno di noi per
recuperare il cielo stellato
in realtà si tratta di illuminare bene e
non di restare al buio perché tutta
questa luce inutilmente scagliata verso
il cielo è sprecata e la luce che arriva
per esempio dai lampioni a globo ne
vediamo tanti
arriva dai fari ma scherma stati e mal
direzionati e da una illuminazione che è
sempre comunque eccessiva se tutti noi
amministratori cittadini
impiantisti elettricisti tecnici
prestarsi ma attenzione alle nostre
scelte per quanto riguarda
l'immigrazione
privata e urbana già gran parte del
problema sarà risolto ed eviterà i modi
realizzare ancora oggi degli impianti
che non rispettano i vincoli sulla
tutela del cielo notturno
[Musica]
tra l'altro i costi dell'inquinamento
luminoso sono esorbitanti quanto assurdi
l'osservatorio conti pubblici italiani
università cattolica di milano a testa
che l'italia consuma il doppio della
media europea in illuminazione pubblica
e addirittura il quintuplo rispetto ai
tedeschi lo vediamo bene in questi
grafici qua dietro la spesa annua pro
capite per l'illuminazione pubblica nei
paesi europei valori né euro e vediamo
che l'italia è in testa e il flusso
luminosa pro capite notturno in
chilowattore vediamo la differenza tra
italia e germania abbiamo molto da
lavorare ed effettivamente i progetti
pilota condotti in alcuni comuni
italiani virtuosi
indicano che ci potrebbero essere
riduzioni di consumo
sicuramente nel 50 60 fino addirittura
all 80 per cento
e non c'è solo la bellezza del cielo e
lo spreco di denaro in gioco l'eccessiva
esposizione alla luce artificiale
notturna è causa di squilibri ormonali
dannosi per l'uomo e gli altri mammiferi
ricollega abbia forme di ansia di
depressione e addirittura all'insorgenza
e lo sviluppo di alcuni tipi di tumore
che sono collegati ai cicli ormonali
oggi c'è la tendenza a sostituire i
vecchi impianti con i led purtroppo live
bianchi quelli ad alta temperatura che
mettono una enorme quantità di luce del
blu e della luce del blu che per esempio
blocca la produzione di melatonina
durante le ore notturne
questo aumenta il rischio di elevati
effetti negativi sulla salute umana
quindi è un bene sostituire i vecchi
impianti
comunque le nuove molto più efficienti
ma ecco
usiamo il led ambra quelle a luce calda
e soprattutto contemporaneamente
diminuiamo il numero di punti che
installiamo
la luce artificiale nottuna provoca
enormi danni ambientali
interferisce nei cicli biologici degli
animali soprattutto quelli che vivono di
notte che non si riproducono e non si
alimentano più come un tempo sconvolgono
le rotte migratorie e tutta una serie di
effetti dannosi su flora e fauna che
provocano una
complessiva perdita di biodiversità
oltretutto è ormai assodato che non c'è
nessuna relazione tra una maggiore
illuminazione e una diminuzione
nelle venti criminosi o degli incidenti
stradali e quindi il messaggio finale
che voglio la sharia illuminiamo meno
illuminiamo meglio perché abbiamo solo
da perderci se non contrastiamo tutti
insieme l'inquinamento luminoso ci
perdiamo in denaro in salute in
biodiversità ma soprattutto in bellezza
perché il cielo stellato è stato ed è e
deve rimanere una fonte d'ispirazione
per tutta l'umanità come ha scritto
mario star in occasione di un black out
nazionale qualche anno fa il buio fuori
può far accendere la luce dentro ea
tutti voi quello che io posso posso
sperare per tutti quanti noi è che di
vivere un black out almeno una volta
nella vita con un cielo sereno vi
ringrazio
[Applauso]